your iPad might be a shiny new toy that
you just got for Christmas or a trusted
gadget that you've had for a long time
but either way one thing you'll know all
will be about to find out is that sky
news for iPad means graphics how we
display information for complex and
interesting subjects is a collaborative
process between our producers and our
graphics experts will here to talk us
through our top five interactive
graphics from this year is Chazz Buffett
our head of design here at Sky News now
just let's let's start with number one
on Nelson Mandela graphic here which
really tells the story of his struggle
against apartheid doesn't it just tell
us a bit about the color choice here and
the images we're looking at so the the
selection process for the mandela
graphic was interesting because it's
more about taking a celebratory tone
whereas there was a lot of reverential
output going on around there and what we
find in the graphic here is a beautiful
illustrative style very much in keeping
with the tribal designs of Africa but
also poster art from the periods and
it's indicative when we go down to
things like the sharpeville massacre the
styling on there is very much from the
period and then the flow throughout the
sequence of what is basically a digital
poster is is beautiful it always has an
indication for where to move on to next
and I think that's important in any form
of interaction is it hard to use bright
colors and yet maintain a feeling of
respect very much so i think i think
what worked well here was selections of
the colors from the flag is is a
fantastic way of doing that but also as
we say if you take something that's
indicative of the heritage behind behind
the man behind the history of the
country that way you can always be
reverential and celebratory at the same
time so number two
console wars now this was a graphic to
chart the evolution of video games
consoles really absolutely I I love this
design and it's clearly a labor of love
for everyone that was involved in it if
you think about a piece of interaction
where it's so in tune with the
information that it is exactly what it
was supposed to be from the start you
need to play the game in order to reveal
the information right down to revealing
the little what we'd call Easter eggs of
information every time you tap on one of
the question marks and styling again
going back to the nintendo entertainment
systems of the 80s and the sega is is so
pure and so true to form one of the the
tiny little bits that i really love
about it if you go into the expo section
at the end all of the characters created
within their our avatars of the
designers that worked on the project the
actual designs who worked on it and that
brings me to my next question was it a
team ID or was it based around one
person's conception it was it was sold
as a product from from a communication
so all of the best interaction that you
can have is a marriage of editorial and
design and development and as soon as
you've got those people working together
they will always formulate a better idea
was it fun to make absolutely hilarious
staring at people's avatars a favor
typically how many hours would this take
to create with something like this this
was conceived about three weeks before
launch but in terms of the man-hours
within that there's at least two weeks
of hard graft and development design
time within fantastic next up
immigration this coincided with our sky
news immigration week which was actually
looking at whether it was a good or a
bad thing for the UK so just talk us
through the the color schemes we've got
going on here and the various different
bits of information per trade through
the graphics on the
sure so in terms of of the overall brand
design across the channel and all
digital outputs the the theory was taken
from transit silage the kind of things
that you've seen departure lounges at
airports the arrows pointing you in
directions there were a variety of
colors explored and yellow and blacks
and grays seemed to come to the fore
very quickly strictly speaking not very
much Sky News brand colors but when you
have an idea that will translate so
literally across something like this
it's clear that you need to go with it
from the start and there's an awful lot
of information here is it hard to
include a lot of information without
looking too busy very much and this is
where the navigation comes into play
soon as you have anything which requires
a level of interaction from the user and
a level of freedom from them you need to
section off as much as possible and what
we have here is a very simple navigation
down the left hand side beautifully
simple iconography but what's
interesting is as you scroll through the
pages you have the same sections through
everything sits in the same kind of
place you have your videos to play and
then you have your nice little
infographics beautifully illustrated for
most part translating the information
was clear very clear so next up John F
Kennedy and the anniversary marking 50
years since his assassination now here i
can see you based it on the us-flagged
there along with a photo of him just
tell us a bit about the decision behind
that I think the the overall styling for
the JFK and again this translated very
well on to where it's it's very much
about being indicative of the time
period during which he lived without
being too clichéd and if we can keep
that clean essence of the time whilst
still translating the information that's
where we get beautiful design that that
really feels in motive to a time period
in particular I think when you go down
through the sections what you get is
clearly again there's an awful lot of
information to go through but it's very
nicely broken up with a little bit
the little kind of sections there's a
section of musicians yeah it's a very
good breakup of everything that we get
and finally onto our look at the Sistine
Chapel so here we see a graphic which
explains the process of how a new pope
is chosen and what really took me was
the extraordinary detail inside the
sistine chapel was that was that
difficult to replicate it's difficult to
replicate but it's interesting that you
pick up on that because the whole focus
of this was about focus and the focus is
on the Sistine Chapel this is the
imagery that everyone knows this is the
imagery that everyone understands and
this is when most of the action takes
place so the overall impression of the
Vatican City of sim Peters is a very
heavenly approach but very simplistic
and it's not until we go into the sixth
Sistine Chapel that the level of detail
is revealed and that's what we
concentrated on here again when you go
into the navigation it's it's about
keeping that simplicity of information
to the fore at all times so it's great
to have the decoration great to have the
beauty but ultimately you need to focus
on the information within char's thanks
for joining us